but that was our holidays were real you
know and then Christmas was just did
they have Santa would you ever do a
Greek Santa not a Greek yeah Greek Santa
tell me what you want har you know over
here oh beautiful girl come here S Greek
Santa's like the 16-year-old hostess at
the diner like you tell me I tell you
what you want no problem come here I
have I have for you you not tell my wife
Miss Claus don't need to
know yeah Greek said all the kids get a
handful of feta from his pockets it's
like Rich inside not to deep do not rich
deep everybody have to have
feta yeah but we waited we waited in
line to see Santa Claus yeah oh I loved
all that I loved all that Whimsical
American because that's the other
thing Greek people do Christmas actually
not a big deal New Year's is when you
give give presents but my they tried
that and we were like look
you move to America I'm getting my
ony I'm getting my on December 25
maybe even the 24th but yeah we were
just yeah I I'm trying to think of what
they had in our town if we would go see
a Santa you have a little hoot nny they
had a dude yeah they used to have this
place it was like uh secondary bread or
something you ever seen one of them
shops where it's like you go get the
bread but they should have sold it yes
the other day sure yeah yeah yeah soup
kitchens your mom's like we're going to
a store
Theo it's all bread in
there but they'd have a dude over there
he would pull up this kind of cage and
Santa bro and he be like what do you
want there Bo you know yeah come on sit
on Santa left that here we going to get
your
boy yeah cajan Santa what you want you
want a
list like he he gave out the L
like he gives out lisps he's like you
have ailments from cun Santa you got a
cliff lip n boy you going to wake up
without your front tooth you want a
little cleff pallet from Santa huh yeah
your left leg is going to be two inches
longer than your right leg from now on
let me see if I got a little polio in my
sack for y there
boy let me get something that slow you
down in the
swamp the Friendship of an alligator he
just he gives you mystical
presence there will be one Gator he'll
be your friend but there'll be three
Gator be your
enemy he would be like let me hold your
hand and we together we'll pray for your
dead twin that was never born I'm like
dead twin his eyes roll back in his head
he's like tell Mommy Todd's gonna get
her
next oh that's too much santoria for one
day for oh I need
gumbo quick get him some gumbo so he can
tell the
future oh man get that boy craw dead
somebody get the let him suck on the
head somebody let him suck on the head
so keep his his powers keep his iner y
yeah that's his present too it's like CW
dad he didn't suck on to completion I
left a little head on the meat little
meat on the head there for you boy you
been a good boy I got you a hot warm
oyster out of my pocket
let me give you a warm oy and a couple
knockan
tablets welcome to New Orleans
baby this here little Wayne's a box of
shorts from when he was in the hot boys
yeah yeah we got a picture of Lil
Wayne's box of short
fire police investigating viral photo
taken at mall Louisiana Santa cash and
gun let's see what happened here there
they go that's sick oh yeah
there's some dude oh that's a great pick
and what the article says there brother
I hope the police are searching them to
give them the key to the city Baton
Rouge photo showing two men posing with
stacks of cash and a handgun alongside
of Mall
Santa that's a sick look dude
and look at s he's dab he's doing a dab
dude that's awesome he's one he's a
couple dances behind that's I'm trying
to catch on the Black Culture yeah dude
dab came after the doggey bro get it
together one of the one of the men seen
in the photos 29-year-old Almanzo Paul
Almanzo is such a sick name oh it is
just not no no not
Alonzo Almanzo throwing an extra m in
Alonzo it's a power move
Almanzo dude yeah I love it yeah was
arrested Thursday on an unrelated warant
out of Texas wow so snitching they for
having some Christmas cheer it's
illegal to have a nice time with Santa
Claus now I think it's the 9mm that got
him I thought this I thought this was
America that could be a Glock yeah one
of the most American Christmas pictures
I've ever seen what are you supposed to
do not go shopping he's got money it's
Santa's at a mall he's putting money
back into the economy true and
he's protecting himself with his second
amendment rights now did he get that
strictly legally who's to say oh now we
care about red government red
tape yeah how do we know we in't a
lifeguard bro
that's and we need more black lifeguards
we need more black lifeguards and those
pools get testy yeah let's just say this
we need more black lifeguards look at me
Biden